hey everyone this is Steve Electro with
collider and I am here in the our
Sundance Studio which is being sponsored
by Saratoga Spring Water I want to give
them a huge shout out because it costs a
lot of money to be here sponsors are
important thank you so much uh but the
reason I get to be here today is to talk
to the people behind Fremont and I
really want to give you a
congratulations and how much I enjoyed
your movie
um uh congrats on being part of Sundance
but uh most people who are going to be
watching this interview right now will
have not seen the film yet so I hate
doing this but how have you been
describing it to like friends and family
well thank you for having us here
um
two friends and family
um to anyone this is a story about a
young Afghan woman who used to work as a
translator for the US Military
and has recently moved to the Bay Area
and lives in the city of Fremont which
is right outside San Francisco and by
day works in a Chinese fortune cookie
factory and it's about someone
restarting their life you know a
Stranger in a Strange Land
um I have to ask you you have never made
a film before and uh I I really want to
know how you got involved in this and
what the experience was like uh you know
being front and center in a movie
uh thank you so much uh yes that was my
first time acting in a movie uh first I
received an email from my one of my
friends and I sent an email to babak and
we had uh like uh so many times
Zoom call and after that
we decide to work together actually he
decided to work with me I was going to
be like it was probably his decision
yeah probably exactly and yeah
um uh but what was it like the
experience of making a movie compared to
maybe what you thought it would be
I have to say I worked as a journalist
in Afghanistan for two years so I had
and for I had experience in front of
camera and microphone so it was for me
easy to be in front of cameras uh but
working with the cast and film crew and
director was like a first time I really
enjoyed it and I learned a lot from it
and also from dunya's character you play
a an integral part of this film actually
instead of me saying it can you talk
about who you play and what was it about
this part that said I want to do this
um well I play a doctor a psychiatrist
who's uh I I've heard somebody call him
eccentric recently which was a maybe a
Kinder description than that I've been
using when I've been telling people
about it but uh
uh yeah just an oddball you know
psychiatrist I guess one of these people
that probably
when he started in the profession was
quite good but has maybe gone to seed
over the years
um and uh yeah basically when babak
reached out and I read the script I was
just excited to have been asked you know
as opposed to like when I got the script
to audition for the Elmer Fudd movie uh
no but but this but this I mean it's a
beautiful beautifully written script and
it's kind of a dream really to get
something like that and be offered a
role in it when you but the quality is
glaring from the get-go no completely um
one of the things I really enjoyed the
way you shot it in black and white and
how you framed uh all the scenes so can
you talk about how you decided on the
aesthetic of the film
yes uh Laura valadeo who's the
cinematographer in the film and I
um we just had a gut feeling this would
work better in black and white
to sort of let's say
show the in essence the uniformity of a
play of places whether it's a commuter
town like Fremont or a major city like
San Francisco and uh and having seen you
know having having locations in mind
such as the cookie factory and the
inside of the owner's apartment the
psychiatrist office everything just
seems to me to
to us to me and Laura to work better in
black and white and the framing
is primarily static there's some
handheld
motion shots in motion when she's
walking donors walking around the city
but the static element is to let's say I
mean I'm
medium photography was a big influence
in the way we decided to shoot this film
medium format photography and um
I think the good thing great thing about
medium format photography is that
um
you allow things in your mind to happen
within imagine what's happening within
the frame you know I mean like you don't
expect things to come in and out of it
you expect to focus on what's there and
that's with the static elements here
um I would hope the audience would
really when they see for example I don't
know Donia and uh Dr Anthony in the
office of the psychiatrist they come
they know that what they're watching
nothing's gonna happen now no one's
going to come into the frame to take a
piece of paper or to pass on information
it's just that which is happening that
was the intention there's a a really
great scene with you and your boss
um I don't want to talk specifics
because I want people to you know it's
too early for anything specific but
there's a scene with you and your boss
in the factory uh and it's very long
take and he's talking with you
um and again I don't want to be specific
but it's very well done and um can you
sort of talk a little bit about working
on scenes like that where
um you know you're sharing a scene with
someone else again you've never done a
movie and what it's like when the camera
is on you for that long you know what I
mean
yes I got it that was time I used that
it doesn't feel like um
not being okay with that so I I said I
had experience in front of camera so I'm
I'm fine with it yeah
I think yeah also a long take like that
you mentioned without revealing what was
happening
um you're relying on both of them
pulling it off and and they literally
got it in the first egg
and their reactions to each other was um
it wasn't really rehearsed we didn't we
didn't have time for reverse I don't
like rehearsing anyways so it was very
natural we just you know said this is
good do this do that and they went with
it and they reacted to each other's you
know um expressions or words and things
like that uh one thing I want to add
um I really try to be myself in the
movie yeah
that's that's right out of the movie
yeah
um one of the things about this is that
you obviously have to make this on a
budget you had a I'm sure a tight
schedule so what were some of the
challenges that you were up against to
try to pull this off in with the you
know the limitations that you were given
you know our limitations were similar to
most Independent films I think um
we didn't have too many shooting days
and all these things and we um we're
shooting covet was still around so we
were fearful of that you know someone
Falls ill we have to
um how do we do this which I did
yes indeed
um and um but
other than that I mean we had a great
production team Rachel Fong Sydney's
Roth George Rush Laura Wagner Chris
Martin they were really on top of things
and the crew as well was um everyone
really though good sports basically I
think everyone
um
really was on board to
um how should I say this
um
they I mean we all knew let's say
whatever limitations we had no one was
surprised by it
um and it's a fact that when you make
Independent films you're faced with such
things but having like I said you know
um in scenes where um for example Greg
who's a professional he's done this
whole bunch of times
um helps of course because
um he's let's say he's on top of it from
the word go like with Greg we didn't
like there's no audition I wanted Greg
for the world because I've been a big
fan of this for years so it wasn't like
hey you know let's have an audition see
how you do it was kind of like would you
be in this film please and when he said
yes it was great and um and like you
know when they when he for example sat
in front of a non-professional actress I
think his presence helped her and her
presence helped him so I think those
kind of things
um helped us move things forward quicker
than we thought we would if that makes
sense what I'm saying no 100 100 one of
the things though that um oh yeah one of
the things that I uh appreciate is that
you know there's a lot of people who
helped America in Afghanistan that have
been brought over to America and I don't
want to say that they're forgotten about
but they're forgotten about and um I
guess I am saying it and so uh I'm just
was that one of the reasons why you felt
compelled to tell this story originally
when I heard about translators living in
Fremont that's what Drew my attention
because of the way they were living they
have been forgotten about neglected and
things like that so that was you know
the original idea of doing a film about
a translator stem from that that I found
it shocking
um but this the story kind of sort of
changed but the um the reality is that
yes there are people who risk their
lives for America over there and once
they came here they were kind of
abandoned and which
is something that's often repeated in
history yeah I mean the law America is
great at doing this it really it's
fantastic I can say this as an American
um I am not American so I won't say this
right I can say this America is great at
forgetting people
um so talk a little bit about for the
two of you when you think back on the
shoot what's like the day or two that
you will always remember
I mean I think just the first scene even
because I didn't know exactly what I was
getting into and I just met her and from
the first scene I felt so comfortable
with her and felt like we had a good
chemistry and a good rhythm in what we
were doing and that there was no reason
to worry and she was very inspirational
to me because I felt like
this is Quite a feat to star in a movie
uh fresh out of Afghanistan and new to
the English language and here she's
given this incredible burden and
sometimes I thought
does she memorize some of this dialogue
by the syllable or or you know because I
mean just in seeing you here I've seen
how much your English has just really
blossomed compared to even then you know
so I think that Comfort level really
made it easy I don't think we had to do
many takes of anything other than for
coverage we just kind of had this nice
rhythm going and and just nailed it as
they say now I want to add a New England
country it's not easy to learn a new
language and be with people and make
company so in this in the seat see yeah
on the set uh
Greg Jeremy everyone but back everyone
was supportive and I really appreciate
it and
I tried my best no you did a great job
um I really have to I could talk a lot
more but um we have to wrap due to the
time limitations but I'm just going to
say I'm really happy you guys came in
I'm really uh so happy for you that
you're part of Sundance and thank you
for your time thank you for having me
thank you so much I just want to add a
little things don't forget don't forget
about Afghanistan about women of
Afghanistan and stay with them talk
about them have
um like remember them what's going on
there and they're they lost their rights
I am glad you brought that up you're
here yes thank you